good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday where all
the news stacks up we told you the
beginning of the week that canada had
descended into tyranny and in fact it
has justin trudeau has declared that he
controls all the money in canada he can
take yours at will
today trudeau had non-violent protesters
and independent reporters arrested in
some cases they were trampled with
horses
these are the most egregious human
rights violations by a western
government in recent memory and yet the
biden administration is encouraging all
of it biden's state department has
refused to criticize justin trudeau and
his successes in any way
instead our mannequin in chief spent yet
another day yammering on about ukraine
as if we're supposed to believe that's
more important than our own problems
what country is this guy in charge of
anyway someone ought to tell him
and in fact we were going to tell him
right at the top of tonight's show that
was our lead a serious topic for a
serious time
and then out of nowhere we received an
early copy of take up space the
unprecedented aoc
it's a book length suck-up to alexandria
ocasio-cortez by the editors at new york
magazine it's coming out next week
now a hagiography of sandy cortez is
like a box of fig newtons you know it's
wrong to open it but the temptation is
strong and so we did and before we knew
it we consumed the whole thing we still
feel sick
so that is what we're opening with
tonight the new sandy cortez book yes
it's a lighter topic than tyranny in
canada or war in ukraine both of which
we will get to in a minute our only
excuse is it's friday and we've got
limited self-control with stuff like
this
it's an amazing book let's put it this
way it opens by comparing ocasio-cortez
to jesus
and then it suggests that because she
once got second place in a high school
science competition she could have gone
on to win the nobel prize
it is a remarkable piece of journalism
we plan to put extensive excerpts from
the book on the screen tonight for you
to read and then we thought who reads
anymore not sandy cortez she never reads
reading is racism it's so
white people
so instead we've asked our senior
producer alex mccaskill to read the
passages for us you may recognize alex
mccaskill's melodious outer london
inflected voice from the stacey abrams
softcore porn novels that we have
featured on the show we've asked him
today to compare these two projects he
said he found this one creepier we'll
let you be the judge here's a section in
which the fan girls at new york magazine
let us know why they wrote this book in
the first place there are a lot of
politicians they could have farmed over
they picked sandy cortez because she's a
lady
to say she is a feminist is to
understate the facts
ocasio-cortez is the first politician in
history to live fully out loud while
female
and the degradations of womanhood are
personal to her
so she's not just the first woman to
represent her congressional district in
the state of new york she's the first
woman in human history to get elected to
something and then quote live fully out
loud while female
what exactly does that mean is it a
trans thing honestly we don't know she's
definitely loud
but we did understand the next line the
degradations of womanhood are personal
to her
well that's certainly true no one has
done more personally to degrade american
womanhood than sandy cortez has she is
living proof that 60 years of feminist
liberation did not work
sandy cortez is not empowered she's
neurotic and silly she is far more
frivolous than any 1950s housewife ever
was june cleaver was a more serious
person at least she made dinner
here's what sandy cortez does she puts
on makeup while talking about herself
as the youngest woman in congress
it's and as a woman of color it's so
hard to be taken seriously
it's
just
you know it's like any workplace where
sometimes it feels like you have to jump
up and down for anyone to listen it's
just really difficult because some
people are just born in
bodies that are naturally
taken more seriously people already try
to diminish me and diminish my voice as
young and frivolous and unintelligent
they don't take me seriously when i put
on eyeshadow people are calling me
unintelligent just because i'm dumb
it's pretty funny but the funniest of
all was hearing sandy cortez describe
herself as a woman of color
she often does no one ever dares to
challenge that description but every
honest person knows it is hilariously
absurd there is no place on earth
outside of american colleges and
newsrooms where sandy cortez would be
recognized as a quote woman of color
because she's not she's a rich entitled
white lady she's the pampered obnoxious
ski bunny in the matching snowsuit who
tells you to pull up your mask while
you're standing in the lift line at
jackson hole they're all the same
doesn't matter what shade they are
apparently the editors at new york
magazine don't ski
they spend the entire book pretending
that sandy cortez has just emerged from
some teeming favela in the slums of rio
to save the world's poor
reading it you would have literally no
clue she was a credentialed member of
the over class you'd think she was saint
francis
on the day of the house vote
ocasio-cortez stood up in the chamber
again wearing all white
she looked like a prophet or a medium
tapping a deep well of popular fury
radiant and white in her gowned
bathed in the glow of holy righteousness
a prophet for our time
imagine isaiah but with nails to match
the handbag that's how new york magazine
describes sandy cortez and that's weird
because we live in this country too and
that's not at all how we remember the
moment
here's a clip from the speech the book
is referring to
look at this person and ask yourself if
you can feel god's presence
but we have to go into this vote eyes
wide open what did the senate majority
fight for one of the largest corporate
bailouts with as few strings as possible
in american history
a prophet
or proof that adderall abuse is more
common than we admit we'll let you
decide we will tell you that the editors
at new york magazine are highly
impressed by the way ocasio-cortez looks
they think she's hot it's a major theme
in the book and in fact it's a major
theme with ocasio-cortez herself she
talks about her beauty constantly just a
few weeks ago she let us know how hard
it is that everyone wants to sleep with
her all the time what a burden it's like
living as a nudist in the dallas cowboys
locker room men are so aroused by her
tick-tock videos she can barely get
through a day yet she does her job
anyway that's why she's a hero the
burden of sexiness weighs heavily on her
sleek and tawny shoulders but she bears
up under it
listen to new york magazine's account
ocasio-cortez would have been well aware
of her impact on others
her rhetoric could be confrontational
and her politics counter-cultural but
her appearance conformed to society's
conventions
with her wide apart eyes
arched brows and tawny complexion she
could have modeled for a skincare line
and in fact later capitalized on these
assets by shooting a makeup tutorial for
vogue
she could have been a model for a
skincare line and that's why she's such
an amazing political leader because
she's so
pretty imagine a man saying that it'd
probably be considered patronizing if
not grounds for cancellation
but new york magazine isn't ashamed to
objectify alexandria ocasio-cortez
it makes you wonder what would happen if
one day she gained 100 pounds and got
eczema on her nose and forgot to trim
her ear hair
we know what would happen her political
influence would evaporate instantly
she's not the leader of an ideological
movement she's a living marketing
campaign
here she is selling
cosmetics i
really like starting to blend with my
fingers
and then i'll go in afterwards and
polish it off i've been lately playing
with a lot of eyeshadows i go in with
a little kind of a lighter color
um and i would just wash it all over my
lid i tried the shimmer
and it it looks fire it looks good
whenever you see me wearing a red lip um
most of the time it's this one
and again i start small and i start
working my way
out
voila
so makeup is a process you know you
start small and then you work your way
out concentric circles that's the way
she uses cosmetics we have to but she
seems pretty good at it painting her own
face may be her one real skill
but something useful that's a different
story
watch this cnn account of her attempt to
assemble her own ikea furniture
oh shoot
five second rule
hey everyone she was munching popcorn
sipping white wine and assembling
furniture on instagram live all right
what am i doing here aoc moved into our
washington apartment three months ago
but has been too busy to furnish it did
i do this wrong
boom
i did it
obviously there are a lot of
self-involved people in politics all of
them pretty much
but it takes a special kind of
narcissist to imagine that the world
desperately wants to see you bowl
together a particle board coffee table
but new york magazine can't get enough
of it here's their account of what you
just saw on this night and again during
another session assembling ikea
furniture in july
she shone a bright light on her own
complicated multifaceted self in that
video ocasio-cortez looks thin
her trousers sag she's wearing her
glasses and her hair is up in a sloppy
just about to wash my face bun
she's wearing an old moto jacket and is
sitting on the floor of her unfurnished
apartment eating a bowl of popcorn and
drinking a glass of wine
for dessert she has a small pack of
fruit snacks sent to her in bulk by
roberts's mother
she has no agenda nothing in particular
to get off her chest
it really is if she were exhausted and
wanting to talk
i'm alone today she says pointedly at
the camera
imagine if you were the person who wrote
that
so here's this crazed solipsist filming
herself as she puts together a coffee
table and eats popcorn okay the least
compelling film made since andy warhol
died
and this is what you call it she's shown
a bright light on her own complicated
multi-faceted self that's the moment you
have to be honest with yourself and say
it's time for me to retire
by the way the person who wrote this
didn't even perceive how creepy it was
i'm alone today ocasio-cortez says
pointedly at the camera is it just us or
does that sound like an invitation to a
booty call maybe one step from what are
you wearing
either way it's a little strange it's
definitely over sharing
and yet according to the book over
sharing is the key to sandy cortez's
success
she offered the reassuring warmth of
oprah
the fire and brimstone of jonathan
edwards
the inspiration of john f kennedy
the intimacy of an fdr fireside chat it
was exhausting and reassuring and scary
and comforting and extremely weird
the intimacy of an fdr fireside chat
sure except that fdr never told us about
his skin care regimen somehow he was
able to win the second world war anyway
you wonder how he did that you also
wonder what brand of concealer he used
sadly there was no instagram then so the
details have been lost to history
thank kevin we know what sandy cortez
uses
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else